in preparation for hurricane season it'd
be a good idea for livestock producers
to review their their health program
because there's always the potential
that animals may be relocated to a
shelter or another farm to get them out
of dangerous way and the other situation
that could arise is you know storms can
do a lot of damage
knock fences down and potentially then
in that situation animals could go
mingle with other herds as well and just
be exposed to other infectious diseases
so so having a herd health program up to
date having vaccinations up to date
would be a good thing another situation
that that could arise is when animals
are commingled trying to get them back
to their proper owner so animal
identification is very important and it
needs to be unique animal identification
something that is specific to that
animal into that farm and so for example
hot brands USDA e mental ear tags
electronic identification tags those
would all be potentially unique animal
identification as opposed to say a
dangle tag with just a number on it
you know there's a lot of there's a lot
of black cows in Alabama that probably
have an ear tag number 26 in their year
for example so it needs to be something
unique to that particular animal so that
that people can get the animals back to
their to their proper farms of course
making sure that you have all the
equipment on hand that you need to to
respond to to a potential disaster
making sure that you have feed and water
available and in storage for one to two
weeks potentially for stored feed it
needs to be stored in a dry safe place
and it needs to be someplace that's
that's fairly secure so that you do have
good healthy wholesome feed to provide
your your livestock after a disaster if
you're on a well water source having
hand pumps or generators available in
case electricity is disrupted would be
would be all the important things to
consider ahead of time livestock
producers should prioritize their
animals so that they can be sure that
those animals if animals do have the
opportunity or the need to be evacuated
those animals with a high priority can
then be evacuated first or looked after
first if the producer knew which animals
were maybe getting ready to calve or a
kid or phone whatever the case may be
put them in in a location where they can
maybe check on them
first to make sure that there haven't
been any complications or any issues
that arise during the during the storm
if you are in an area that is prone to
flooding
for example move move your animals to
higher ground and ideally keep them out
of barns they're usually going to be
better left in large open spaces as
opposed to confined to a barn the last
thing you want to do is put your animals
in there and then have the storm destroy
that building with all your animals in
it so they're usually going to be better
off on high ground in large open spaces
particularly if the horses are not used
to being out in the pasture in that
situation it may be safer and a better
idea to leave them in a stall in a
secure building because last thing you'd
want to have happen is a storm to come
in scare the horses frighten the horses
and and they you know don't know how to
handle that don't know what to do and
they may end up injuring themselves more
so than the storm
you